du théâtre au cinéma avec le festival de
cannes et deux enfants chéris de la
compétition les frères dardenne
les réalisateurs belges avait obtenu la
palme d'or il ya cinq ans avec rosetta
ils montrent à nouveau les marches ce
soir pascal deschamps nadine picard sur
place jean pierre lui l'udc jean-pierre
aujourd'hui on ne les appelle plus que
les dardenne des frères venus de
belgique pour nous raconter des
histoires simples au titre simple après
la promesse rosetta le fils voilà
l'enfant un enfant dont ils ont accouché
juste avant le festival de cannes c'est
tellement important
on entre ciney mal passé comment les
choses peuvent se passer ici mais c'est
là bon là on a lâché notre film au
public c'est plus notre hymne c'est fini
l'enfant c'est l'histoire de bruno à
gauche un jeune homme plein
d'insouciance qui vit de petits larcins
et qui se retrouve du jour au lendemain
enfin pas trop mal les dardenne filmo
ces gens là comme le chantait un autre
belge célèbre natale en ce moment ceux
que l'on croise ou que l'on juge sans
avoir vraiment envie de les connaître on
aime bien ces gens là on aime bien
raconter leur histoire les mettre en
scène et pas pour les enfermer dans leur
histoire mais pour essayer que leur
histoire parle de l'époque parle de vous
de nous et fasse réfléchir longtemps
faut que ça coule mais pour quoi faire
pour connaître
dans une heure et demie les frères
dardenne montrons les fameuses marches
et présenteront leur film au jury d'ici
là ils auront accordé leur dernière
interview une cinquantaine depuis ce
matin un planning ferrer temps les
journalistes veulent rencontrer ses
frères couvert de prix il faut dire que
cannes leur a déjà offert une palme d'or
et deux prix d'interprétation
alors